تتعدد الطرق والماساه واحده في لبنان
الموت يبدو انه اصبح اسهل من الحياه
بالنسبه للبعض موجات من حالات الانتحار
موجه تتحول ازمه في بلد يعاني من تعدد
الازمات اعمار مختلفه للمنتحرين في
الاسبوعين الماضيين توحي بعمق المشكله على
الصعيد النفسي والصحه العقليه ظاهره
الانتحار تعكس ماساه البعض في ظل الازمه
الاقتصاديه العميقه المزيد من التفاصيل من
لبنان معارض
[موسيقى]
انه لبنان الارض التي تابى ان تريح اهلها
ويابى اهلها الا ان يستريحوا فيها فيقبل
ابنائها على الانتحار تاركينما فوقها من
هموم وازمات ليستقروا تحت ترابها لعله
يكون اكثر هدوءا وطمانينه من المستقبل
المجهول
[موسيقى]
الازمه الاقتصاديه الخانقه التي تعاني
منها البلاد منذ عده اعوام دفعت الكثيرين
الى اللجوء الى الخيار الصعب فمع صعوبه
الحياه اصبح الموت اكثر الطرق سلوكا
لتتصدر حالات الانتحار مشهد الحياه
اليوميه بين اللبنانيين وليحمل الاسبوعان
الماضيان نحو ست حالات انتحار لفئه عمريه
مختلفه
[موسيقى]
وكما يشير الخبراء النفسيون فان الضغوط
التي تقع على كاهل الانسان اللبناني ادت
الى تفاقم اوضاع نفسيه وصحيه معقده من قلق
واكتئاب ليكون التكيف معها صعبا خصوصا مع
ضعف الدعم الاجتماعي الامر الذي يؤدي في
النهايه للعجز والياس الذي يوصل الى اتخاذ
سلوكيات انتحاريه
[موسيقى]
الحياه صعبه في هذه البقعه من الارض لا
يمكن انكار هذه الحقيقه لكن الاصعب هو
اتخاذ مثل هذا القرار الذي لا شك يزيد
الالم والقهر في نفوس من فقد احبتهم نتيجه
لحظات من التفكير السلبي التي ربما يمكن
تجاوزها بالقليل من الامل والكثير من الحب
لصباح العربيه رينادويه
انتحار في لبنان
[موسيقى]
اخصائيه نفسيه والمشرف على خط الحياه
اهلا بك سيفانا معانا في صباح العربيه
يعني تتنامى حالات الانتحار بشكل متسلسل
في لبنان في الاونه الاخيره هل يمكن ارجاع
كل هذه الحالات فعلا الى الوضع الاقتصادي
صباح الخير
يا روبورتال بحب ادور على كم شغله هو
الدراسات الدراسات العلميه انه 10% من من
اسباب الانتحار بعود الى عوامل كثيره
الحالات الانتحار عاده هو موجوده 75%
البلدان الفقيره مثل ما قلتو لبنان اليوم
تحول من
بلد متوسط الدخل لبلد فقير
بشكل ضغط زياده على الاشخاص وعلى
اللبنانيين
فعال اذا هون الاشخاص كان عندهم حالات
نفسيه صادقه اكتئاب التوتر والقلق او فيها
تكون كمان عم تخلق حالات نفسيه جديده عند
الاشخاص عندما تتفاقم التفاعلات والحالات
بيزيد عنده
الشخصيه اكثر في الافكار الانتحاريه او
بيتجه لصديقات الانتحاريه
لانها الضغوطات والالم يلي الشخص عم
يعيشها السيفانا في حالات مختلفه وايضا
امثله مختلفه فيما يتعلق بالانتحار ولكن
بالنسبه للمقدمين على الانتحار في لبنان
فالمساله مشابهه تقريبا بين كل الحالات
اليوم الا يعتبر
الانتحار او محاوله الاقدام على الانتحار
محاوله للهروب من المسؤوليات الملقاه على
الشخص كيف يمكن ان نقنع هذا الشخص بان
يواجه هذه المسؤلات بدلا من ان يهرب منها
الانتحار هو الهروب من المسؤوليات
والضغوطات المعرفيه والاقتصاديه بنكون
كتير عم نبسط
لانه هذا الشخص بيكون غير عن انه عم يختبر
الضغوطات الاقتصاديه والمعاشيه يلي فيها
تكون سبب غير مباشره من انه تكون سبب
مباشر بيكون هذا الشخص كمان عم بيختبر كذا
قصص ثاني بحياته وكذا في عوامل ثانيين عم
بياثر عليك منهم مثلا بيكون هذا الشخص
عنده حاله اكتئاب منهم مثلا هذا الشخص
بيكون على مدى سنين عم يعيش سحب هذا الضغط
هلا لنكون كيف نقنع هذا الشخص ليكون
عم يتجه اكثر ليطلب المساعده من بدل انه
يكون عم ينهي حياته بطريقه الانتحار هو
نكون عم نحكي
الاشخاص عم نحكي عن الصحه النفسيه
وعم ندور على اهميه الصحه النفسيه مثل
الصحه الجسديه وكمان عم نشتغل على مكسر
الوصله لنوصل للاشخاص انه التفكير
بالانتحار هو مش عيب وبالتالي بنكون عم
نشجر هذا الشخص ليكون عم يطلب المساعده
بدل ما يكون عم يلجا للانتحار كوسيم بعلم
النفس بعلم النفس بيقولوا انه في مصطلح
اسمه عدوى الانتحار فهل اصابت عدوى
الانتحار لبنان واللبنانيين اليوم وهنا
الخطوره
هلا صحيح بالمصطلح العلمي لمن نسميها لهذا
الظاهره اللي عم نشوفها بمده اسبوعين وهو
بتسمى عدوى الانتحار
وهذا اللي ظاهره هذا العدوى الانسحار نحن
شفناها كمان في سنه 2019 لما بعتقد بسنه
2019 كمان كانت البدايه للتدهور الاوضاع
مع الاقتصاديه بلب
نان هون
دور الاعلام ما هو الاعلام عنده دور كثير
كبير
لانه
بواسطه سنه 2019 كان الاعلام
يعني عم يخلق رابطه مباشره بين اوضاع
الانتحار وبين انه سبب بسبب الانتحار هو
الاوضاع
والاقتصاديه
كما ذكرت انتم بالتقرير قبل شوي نحن
شهدنا انخفاض حالات الانتشار
وخاصه في سنه 2022 مثل ما قلته كان عنا
138 حاله انتحار ونحن هول الارقام من
السنه من تقرير القوى الامنيه التي تصدر
سنويا فحاليا ما فينا نكون عم نتوقع او
معرفينا نقول انه عم ترتفع
ارقام الانتحار لانه هذه يعني بدنا ننصر
لاخر السنه لنشوف الارقام ونقدر نقارن
بالسنوات الماضيه
ونحن نشكرك جزيل الشكر من بيروت لخصائها
النفسيه والمشرفه على خط الحياه سافانا
طوباليان